that about histamine and cancer.
With this question, I get to refer you to our blog post
and just go to countersclinic.com and look at the blogs
and there's a blog that how does histamine connect to cancer?
There's a research article that I talk about
that with histamine and glioblastoma brain tumors and cancers
but there's other articles,
there are things that reference in there
and articles, a reference in there about breast cancer
as well, there's some research that came out a couple of years ago
and I wrote a blog post about it with breast cancer as well.
histamine, we always think of histamine as a bad thing
so we take it to histamine during the allergy season.
So histamine must be a bad thing.
But remember, all these things that our body creates,
histamine is something that's created by our immune response
is has a purpose.
So histamine itself is not a bad thing.
You have different antibody or excuse me,
different enzymes in your gut
that are made by different genes in your gut
that make enzymes to break down histamines.
That enzyme is called DAO enzyme,
that breaks down histamine in the gut
and it's made by the DAO gene that's in your gut
and if a person has a genetic issue,
meaning they have genetic defects on their DAO genes,
they don't make a lot of the DAO enzyme
and that person can be more prone to having histamine issues
because they're not breaking down histamines from their diet.
So I said our body makes histamines,
but we also ingest histamines.
So histamines are in foods and on our website on the blog
we have a histamine food list that lists out
all the different foods that have high histamines.
So when a person's going on a low histamine diet,
you are just doing that, you're going on a low histamine diet,
you can't not eat any histamines,
there's histamines in everything.
It's a matter of eating things that have a lower quantity
of histamines.
Nuts, really good for you, cashews and walnuts
and things like that, good for your good protein,
a good fat source, but they have a lot of histamines.
Strawberries, strawberries are good for us,
but strawberries have a lot of histamines.
Beads have a lot of histamines.
Lunge meat has a lot of histamines
and even if you make a chicken dinner and you eat it tonight
but you left the leftovers of the fridge,
it's going to have more histamines,
the longer it sits in the fridge.
So if you're eating a leftover,
that's going to have more histamines in it
than if you ate it fresh.
So histamines are not something you can eliminate,
histamines are something that you can decrease.
Now, if your body makes a lot of DAO enzyme in the gut,
you don't really have a lot of histamine issues
from histamines that are ingested.
Histamines are also made in the tissues,
they're made in the body.
Histamines serve a purpose as an immune indicator.
So as an immediate immune response,
the histamines basically signal other immune cells
to come to an area.
So if you're exposed to a lot of pollen,
you breathe in that pollen dust that goes into the tissues
and you'll have an immediate histamine reaction.
Now, why do some people have a worse histamine reaction
than others?
Therefore, they have seasonal allergies.
Well, the truth is they don't necessarily have a worst issue
than others, it's just that they don't clear histamine
as well as a person who doesn't have seasonal allergies.
So a person that has seasonal allergies
doesn't clear histamine in the tissues very well.
There's another gene, your H-N-M-T gene,
that actually makes an enzyme, a DAO enzyme,
in the tissues that clears and breaks down histamine
that's made in the presence of an antigen
like pollen that you are exposed to.
So when you're exposed to something that stimulates
your immune system and it causes a histamine reaction,
normally people, their H-N-M-T gene,
makes this DAO enzyme that breaks down that histamine
and gets rid of it and the person does not have
quote-unquote allergies.
But a person that has defects in that gene
doesn't make as much as that enzyme.
They don't break it down very fast
and they end up having a hyperhistamine reaction.
So what do you do for those things,
those people that have that issue?
And what do you do for a person
that maybe histamine is driving their cancer?
No, if you're like, well, I don't know if histamine
is driving my cancer, well, we tested every single person
whether histamine is driving their cancer.
So you would have been told that.
However, the truth is, as even though histamine
might not be driving your cancer,
it can be problematic.
So decreasing the amount of high histamine foods one eats
or decreasing exposures to antigens
that can cause excess histamines
or even utilizing an antihistamine drug
or an antihistamine supplement can be beneficial.
So corsetin, stingy nettles,
even curcumin could decrease histamines.
We have a product called clear-hist, natural clear-hist,
which is a histamine-reducing supplement
that can be beneficial to reduce histamines in the tissues.
There's also a histamine enzyme
you can literally take the DAO enzyme.
Now, you won't absorb that,
but it will break down histamines in the tissues.
So people that are really bad gut issues due to histamines,
which really aren't any of our cancer patients.
Those would be an autoimmune patient,
but they can take that histamine
and that's called histoclear, that's our product.
And that is actually the DAO enzyme.
So that would break down histamines in the gut
from foods that you're ingesting.
So that's just a little bit more
than you probably want to know about histamines.
Look up on our blog.
We also have multiple web pages on histamines.
Just do a search on our website for histamine,
and you'll see a bunch of pages that I go into,
even more boring detail that I just gave you on histamines.